Where would you suggest to start with curated cystic acting? It really depends on a person's budget. So if you had the budget, I would run those tests, but that can cost you a grant in those tests. They're not cheap tests and your church is not gonna cover those.
If that's not in your budget, I would start with trying to help, trying to heal the gut.
And with removing any things that are constantly causing damage.
So you start by, okay, so if you're making the assumption that a person has increased permeability of their epithelial cells that are gut for leaking gut issues.
Damage got lost.
It's, there's a reason it is, it's because of the ghosts of antibiotic, then there is gonna be inflammatory cytokines that are gonna be developed from that. And there's gonna be because of the leak you got, there's gonna be antibodies to different foods.
And again, the most common ones are when I suggested gluten, getting rid of all gluten in your diet. Look at a gluten clock cross reactants, which is dairy, corn, things like that. But you can't just go on such a restrictive diet that you can't eat anything. So make sure you're eating a lot of different types of vegetables.
But you really want to know what those things are. That's why you do those tests. And then just maybe doing some things that will help heal the gut. Start with the simplest, de-glycerated, licorice, slippery, elm, things like that. We have a product called GI clear GI that can be helpful.
That has a powder that has all that gut healing things in it.
It's actually by 17-year-old son who has the cystic acne. Well, then you should do a case review for your 17-year-old son.
We really shouldn't be asking a lot of questions for our family members on this chat.
So that's how I think we're in some cases.